[Music]
let's go you excited I'm looking forward
thank you very much a media frenzy for
the British Commissioner designate for
financial services Lord Hill the
candidacy of a man accused of having
connections to the city of London has
raised eyebrows but once the cameras
were shoot away Lord Hill embarked on a
charm offensive that I think it's in the
interests of the EU for Britain to be in
it and it's in the interests of Britain
to be in the EU and the big question
conflict-of-interest the one matter that
comes up time and time again is one
about your CV I had some shares which I
was given at the time I sold the
business on being nominated
I gave instructions within or less than
a day of being nominated to get rid of
all of those shares and to the house he
said if I'm confirmed I will be a
European Commissioner who will work for
all 28 member states and a European
Commissioner who never forgets that he
is accountable to the directly elected
members of this Parliament Lord Hale
detailed a five-point plan to tackle
risk close financial loopholes and to
develop a capital Marcus union for all
28 member states but some MEP questioned
his content you show impressive
rhetorical brilliance but also a lack of
substance over in the other room where a
year over the Czech commissioner doesn't
it for justice consumers and gender
equality touched upon a personal story
where she was wrongly detained and later
acquitted on corruption charges a time
that would now serve her well for the
task ahead we should never lose faith
that in the end justice shall prevail in
my case it happened I wanted to put in
place a strong independent and efficient
European public prosecutor's office when
the hearings ended reactions from the
head of the civil liberties committee
whether she
and three other commissioners will be
sharing some of the key issues and
whether that is satisfying for us it is
deeply unsatisfying and how was lord
Hale feeling that I was grateful to have
the chance to speak to the committee
it's a very important committee they've
asked me a lot for very sensible
questions and I was very glad to have
that opportunity thanks very much and so
he left as he arrived but did Lord Hill
do enough to prove he's not the wolf of
the city